um I did something the other night I'm
very ashamed of and I wasn't even going
to say anything but I'm I might as well
say it now but I corrected
myself can I tell you yeah so um Sunday
night I was at the com right spot and um
I get to the store and there's a
waitress at the store her name is Lenny
sweet lady and she comes up to me like
almost like distraught and she goes hey
um Martin Dale's stuck in Austin I don't
know you know I go okay and she's like
and I'm doing the show in the belly room
and I just I have a packed room can you
please do it and I well I have to do
this other o one you know what I mean
and she's like yeah but after I go it
just depends on I feel so then um I go
up in the O and I start talking it's
it's packed and the sound's [__] up
like it's muffled and I can't even hear
myself mhm right and also that night I
was going I love all these new jokes I
want to try and I tried them they didn't
do well right and get off and you know
when you have a weird set it's
frustrating you know you're in a weird
mood and then the sound guy comes up to
cuz I started complaining about it and
the sound comes into goes there's
nothing wrong with the sound man I don't
know what all you copics are talking
about because everyone's complaining
about it right he's like I've tested it
it's perfect I go I go it's not I've
been here for this amount of times you
know what I mean it's never sounded that
way he's like well you I'm telling you
there's nothing wrong with it right I
want want to kill this guy all right but
then now I remember I have to do the
show
upstairs right so I go up there and I
see CP CP up there and he's killing
who's CP he's a black guy oh uhhuh and
um what's so
funny I think that's his
name I don't think it's I think sounds I
think it's wrong CP CP yeah yeah I don't
know the black guy yes C CP black comic
Google that okay um and he's killing
right and and I and I'm now in a [__]
mood like I know I can't perform MH so I
go up to Lenny and I
go and the host this host sweet white
kid and they're like can you please do
it I I'm I know myself I'm in a [__]
mood I just can't they they're like
tears in their eyes please I go oh yeah
I go you want me okay you'll see what
happens like that I go up there
and I purposely I think start eating
it like it's bad W and I can see her
leaning against the wall like this
looking at me and I'm like you
happy like like an [__] I end the set
and then the host comes to shake my hand
and I diss him geez I'm being honest
yeah yeah I'm being honest I leave the
club and and also also in the hallway
I'm like screaming I told you I don't
want to go up you know what I mean like
like a [__] maniac right yeah then I
couldn't sleep that night next next
morning I woke up I called this kid
Ramsay he gave me her number then you
know I mean and I I called her and I
apologized and I said that was behavior
that
is it's terrible Behavior I told her
what led up to that moment right yeah
and uh normally I would have just let it
go you know what I mean and not said
anything but I'm trying not to do that
so I was like I I wasn't being clear and
I just said I'll make it up to you this
and that but I'm ashamed of my behavior
that night but also the sound guy that
he get it together no yeah yeah you get
back yeah you're right the sound guy I
mean kind of CP CP Chris
Powell yeah I there we go then oh you
just I I no I did Montreal with him he's
so funny and I knew his name was right
but then when I said it you guys were
like that's not a real name for a comic
I go maybe it's suck CP and then I got
[__] paranoid no because I thought
you meant you wanted to
say who's oh my God the Korean dude yeah
okay let me just say something okay let
me say something I thought that's what
you meant to say so you're saying that I
said up on stage killing it and I
couldn't follow him that's
insane that's insane this kid is a beast
I believe it all right but I'm just
saying don't that's insane I know my and
CPS and all that okay okay good good I
know all that right but don't put that
stuff that I they saying the CP is I
mean good I'm just saying that U he's
very talented anyway um yeah uh but
anyway you know I think you know what
you know um you're allowed to make
mistakes and be human but I tried to
mend it right
away I think that it's I get that way
like on the way here on the drive over
here I was in such an okay mood like a
perfectly fine mood like no look at this
guy how pretty you know
and while I got to the corner here
there's a [__] guy just like a big
truck just like